they say the time of Heroes is over but
if you're different you're dangerous
but I know the truth
the world will always be here
just me to reassemble
you
hey guys what's up Marvel drops the best
bond this morning new game in
collaboration with Square Enix so I'm
gonna explain what's going on they're
making a game that's going to tie all
the movies all the comics everything
together in a much more expansive
version of the experience you get when
you go to MCU movies and it's not just
one game it's a series of games so it's
going to feature some of the most iconic
things from the comics and the movies so
because the game isn't out and I can't
give a copy of it away
also a new round of the spider-man
giveaway starts now it's for a copy of
the new spider-man game all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts so you don't
miss anything this all might look a
little familiar to you because the same
studios that's working on this it's
really like a collaboration but it's the
people behind the Tomb Raider games up
until like very recently Deus Ex so just
based on the footage that we see in this
it looks a little bit like those types
of game but they tease that the Avengers
need to resemble and we're heading into
an Avengers here because of Avengers
infinity war so it sounds like this is
going to be like a big RPG style game
they make it seem like it's going to be
a linear RPG like a lot of those other
types of stories but the way they tease
it's going to be playable for a long
time either there's going to be a crap
ton of DLC or they'll just be a series
of games set in this universe with these
characters so you'll be like one of the
Avengers trying to reform the team in
the wake of this giant disaster they
talk about teasing the iconic moments
from the Marvel Cinematic Universe even
though the story is supposed to be
original so it sounds like they'll be
taking all the stuff from the movies and
recontextualizing it a little bit and
you'll get to play around in the movies
just a little bit more with those types
of adventures which I think people want
it's almost like taking one of the big
Avengers films in turning it into a 50
hour event which is what we want for
infinity war I would totally watch a 50
hour infinity war movie so Marvel just
wants you to be doing a lot of Avengers
things going into an Avengers year but
they also have the guard
the galaxy telltale game that's coming
out we haven't seen any real footage
from that just like the logo teaser and
the fact that they're making it Marvel
vs. Capcom infinite they haven't
officially announced what the real title
of the game is going to be or which
characters are going to be playable like
which person you're going to get to
start as presumably it will feature all
of Marvel's main characters from the
comics pending spider-man because
there's all the sony spider-man game
stuff that's happening spider-man is a
big question mark so you guys can let me
know what do you think about the idea of
like a Deus Ex square-enix
Tomb Raider style Avengers game I feel
like everybody's freaking out about this
this is the first big non spider-man
triple-a Marvel game in a while in the
fact that it's coming from Square Enix
is just amazing but for those are you
wondering if it's going to be more like
Final Fantasy or Deus Ex I'm expecting
it to be more like Deus Ex just based on
the look here but they could go any
number of different directions with it
there's no official release date
announced but I'm guessing if these are
going to be Christmas shopping season
this year or sometime early next year
games usually get delayed a lot so
there'll be more trailers for this
they'll release more information as they
go along
they mentioned so much about the movies
and the TV shows in this announcement
though so it just sounds like they're
going to be including all of the MCU
stuff as well as the TV stuff so for
those who use it one of stories that
involves both the movie characters and
the TV characters like infinity where I
know people want them to go into the
movies it sounds like this is the middle
ground as far as gameplay mechanics I'm
expecting Deus Ex but like I said it'll
be like a combination of open-world
and linear RPG just like tons of side
quests so here's a little bit more of
this Deus Ex gameplay footage just to
give you an idea of what that might feel
like y'all dimension era
and with such promise until the incident
turn the world upside down 50 million
dead hundreds of thousands more maimed
and injured all because a few rich
opportunists plotted in secret to
control us today hatred amongst has
morphed into a full-blown mechanical
apartheid with violent clashes fueling
unrest the Augmented are suffering the
genocide
it begins with taking away all rights
treating us as less than human and then
exterminating so you just have to
imagine something that looks and feels
like that universe only done with the
scope and stories and characters of the
Marvel Universe as well as the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so I'm talking about
the comics too so think of Marvel
infinity the classic Infinity Gauntlet
storyline everything that's happened on
earth so far so with each new game it
just sounds like the stories will get
bigger and crazier as we go along
through phase 3 phase 4 of the movies
but they talk about all the environments
all the places the events from the
comics so you might get to see a version
of the Infinity Gauntlet happen you
might get to see stuff from Black
Panther from Thor Ragnarok to stuff from
all corners of the Marvel Universe and I
say universe in the grand sense of thing
so we're talking a space based stuff
earth-based stuff but just to be clear
Marvel and Square Enix's partnership is
for multiple game so either it's going
to be a game series set based on this
new one right here or it's going to be a
couple different types of games but it
sounds more like it's going to be a
series like Tomb Raider or Deus Ex or
something like that so based on the
development cycle that'll probably go
all the way through the fourth Avengers
film and well into Marvel phase four so
you can see how Marvel tries to sort of
like tie its games in its extra
properties into the MCU stuff that's
going on so there'll be a lot of MCU
stuff happening in the game but it'll be
a lot of extra stuff that you don't get
from going to the actual movies so it'll
be a much bigger world a much bigger
story like 50 hours of gameplay versus
two and a half hours of movie so just
really good news this is the best
announcement they could have made it
wasn't an actual MCU movie trailer like
I know everybody wants a Thor trailer
they want more spider-man there'll be
plenty more of that and there's actually
some behind the scenes Avengers infinity
war spider-man that I want to post
there's just a lot of stuff that they've
been doing lately
because they started shooting the movie
so there'll be another infinity war
video sometime on Friday but I have some
new Star Wars so I'm going to post
there's some new Thor Ragnarok so those
will all be the next videos that I post
while you guys wait so that's a post you
can click here for more defenders behind
the scenes and you can click here learn
all about Star Wars Episode 8 thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video